exactly if you're in London you're
having a call with them you go right get
to the point make it about them ask them
all the questions like what would they
dream to be working where would they
love to be or you know who they love to
hire or whatever it is more importantly
who have they not got in their Network
that they would like to have in their
Network show off that you know people
New York is that in New York
particularly is like that La is a bit
Frosty when it's it's more like who do
you know in New York it's how can I help
you know someone right so that the thing
that we learned quite early on is to add
value as soon as we got somewhere and we
go oh yeah you you mentioned that you
might want to do this one day with your
career have you spoken to Jen she's
really good at that yeah cool I'll hook
you up so every meeting you have don't
leave without offering at least an
introduction is one of the things that
we learned